this is a rather strange story of a very
famous scientists who may well have met
his end by not going to the toilet in a
timely fashion the sciences in question
is a guy called Tycho Brahe he who gets
his name mispronounced in many different
ways and I just mispronounce it in yet
another one famous Danish astronomer
from the end of the sixteenth century
who's a bit of a hero among scientists
it must be said in the sense that
firstly he was a brilliant scientist he
made he probably made the first really
precision measurements of astronomical
objects in the heavens made some huge
advances for example he was the first
person who showed really that the
heavens are not immutable that things
actually change up there he was the
first person who really sort of
understood that supernovae exploding
stars were actually not atmospheric
phenomena as they'd been thought to be
were actually things going on in the
heavens and were changing and so that's
part of the reason why is a hero amongst
scientists the other reason he's a hero
among scientists because because he was
an incredible character and we would
like to think you know we have a little
bit about that about ourselves so for
example he famously had a pet moose well
there's a really funny story about Tycho
and as a Canadian it appeals to me
because it's story about a moose and
apparently Tycho had a pet moose or
maybe an elk but we'll call it a moose
but not only that this moose met a very
unfortunate end it fell down the stairs
at a party this tame moose fell down the
stairs because it was drunk got into all
the beer got drunk fell down the stairs
and died and that was the end of Tycho's
moose he had a dwarf in his entourage
who was believed to be psychic and
perhaps the thing he's most famously
known for is that he had a gold nose
having lost his real nose in a dueling
accident with a fellow scientist who
were both arguing over who was the
better mathematician the other thing
that all astronomers know about Tycho
Brahe he is that he was at a banquet and
etiquette demands that you don't leave
the table before your host leaves the
table and he needed to go to the loo and
he sat there and he sat there and he sat
there and by the time he was finally
able to excuse himself the damage had
been done he'd given himself some
serious bladder infection by not going
to the loo in a timely fashion and he
died a matter of days later from the
damage that he done to himself by not
going to the loom so this is actually
was reported by Johannes Kepler
famous astronomer in his own right of
course he was the person who figured out
the nature of the orbits of the planets
around the Sun who was sort of brought
his student and so II and he was with
him sort of on the days leading up to
his death and promised to complete
various of the pieces of work the Breyer
was doing but also wrote an account of
this unfortunate final n turn and of
course from that that's actually a
rather direct link into the whole of
modern physics because Tycho Brahe he
made these first proper measurements
astronomical measurements Kepler then
used bright measurements to figure out
the motions of the planets around the
Sun and of course Kepler's understanding
of the motions of the planets around the
Sun led directly into Newton and his
understanding of gravity and sort of was
responsible for the the birth of the
whole of modern physics so in that sense
I guess he's probably sort of the
great-grandfather of the whole of modern
physics so the thing that's in the news
now is that the cook because this is a
in some ways it's a bit of an urban myth
possibly as the whether or not he really
died that way at the beginning of the
20th century his body was exhumed to try
and figure out whether he'd got a
bladder stone a kidney stone or
something that could have been the cause
of all this and they couldn't find
anything but what they did find was huge
levels of mercury in his moustache hair
and one of the other things that he did
I mean he was a real polymath not only
did you do astronomy he contributed in
medicine he was an astrologer as well
but alchemy was one of the things that
he was loved to dabble in probably
legitimate science then trying to turn
bled and mercury into gold and so he
probably spent a lot of time messing
around with base metals like mercury
which are very poisonous and so the
alternative came along there actually he
might have died of mercury poisoning
instead but the tests that were done at
the time were unfortunately inconclusive
and so now permission has been given to
have the poor man exhumed yet again and
they're going to do some more
sophisticated tests to try and figure
out whether he really was whether he
really did die of mercury poisoning part
of the reason why he sort of appeals to
me as a scientist is he was the first
modern scientist in many different ways
for example one of the things he did was
he set up the first real Research
Institute anywhere and had hundreds of
people there researching what a wide
array of things not just a strongly
again but medicine and alchemy and all
sorts of different areas
but also the way he managed to get the
funding for that in the first place
again sort of appeals to the slightly
more Machiavellian side of the scientist
in me which is that what he did is he
went round various heads of state around
Europe sort of touting his skills as a
scientist and they were all very excited
about him and were starting or offering
him jobs and at that point he went back
to the King of Denmark which was where
he really wanted to be and said to him
look I've got all these offers from all
these Kings around Europe what are you
going to do about it kind of thing and
at that point the the Danish king set
him up and this wonderful Institute and
he was able to make the scientific
advances that he did he's efficiently
famous scientists at least amongst
scientists that actually he has quite a
lot of things named after him various
spacecraft there's a whole catalogue of
stars named after him that was obtained
relatively recently but probably the
single thing that's named often that is
best known is the crater Tycho on the
moon one of the brightest and clearest
of the all the craters on the moon and
something you can see with a very small
pair of binoculars very spectacular
thing